craig edwards still trying to figure out
what the point of a burpee is
aren't we all hi i'm jamie hagia i'm a
crossfit gym owner and coach
and i'll be answering your questions
from twitter this is crossfit support
can you give any pointers to ring muscle
ups and how to string them together
any progression pointers would be great
ring muscle ups
are one of the most difficult movements
it's one of the ones that people come in
and they're like
i want to do that one day basically it's
taking your body there's a set of rings
that hang
and coming all the way up to the top and
doing a dip at the top and that's going
to be a full ring muscle up
getting one by itself is a huge
achievement being able to string them
together
takes it to the next level some of the
things that you can think about when
you're trying to string them together
is when you get to the top instead of
sitting in the l-sit
or pushing yourself far away from the
rings you want to try to stay
nice and tight in a hollow and a hollow
is going to be like a nice bowl shape
like this
so sitting down like that will help you
get back into our arch which is the
transitional piece we need
to go into your second one third one
fourth one
craig edwards still trying to figure out
what the point of a burpee is
aren't we all burpees have become a
least river movement among the
population a burpee is basically
taking your body from a standing
position coming down to the ground and
then coming back up to a full standing
position
the point of it because it is functional
if you were being chased and had to duck
down real quick
get down get back up and run up as fast
as you can we do a lot of them so i see
why people
kind of have this love-hate relationship
with them joe sabin he's an esquire a
lawyer
just one question for crossfit what was
wrong with a normal pull-up
why always chest to bar great question
joe
so in crossfit we do have different
variations of pull-ups
there is your strict pull-up where
you're going to be hanging from a bar
engage your lats and then pull strict
the next one is going to be a kipping
movement a kipping pull-up where you
are going to get an arch and a hollow
and then pull your chin
over the bar so it will be a little bit
of an assistance of a kip
and then the very last one is called a
butterfly pull-up and that's going to be
a more
dynamic pull on the bar a little bit
more movement and they're going to be a
lot
faster and more efficient for pull-ups
in a workout meg
says crossfit question what do i need to
drink this summer when it's blazing hot
in the gym
is water enough or do i need more water
we always want to hydrate especially
when you're in the heat and you need to
stay
hydrated during your workouts 50 shades
of gary
crossfit question do all these shoes
really make a difference in your lifting
are they worth the expense or investment
crossfitters reply
so olympic lifting and crossfit are
gonna be two completely different sports
however
in crossfit we do use olympic lifting in
our movements and in our workouts so
olympic lifting is going to be your
clean and jerk
and then your snatch if you're going for
high volume
lots of repetitions at a high percentage
of olympic lifting
all these shoes are going to be great
for you it is going to be a lifted heel
so it's going to be more
stable for you to squat in and catch in
your position so i would say
they are very beneficial if you guys are
lifting heavy weights in crossfit
andrea has a crossfit question why do a
lot of crossfitters wear
knee-high socks are they compression
socks
is it just because you're curious to
know sometimes for rope climbing
so you don't mess up your shins or box
jumps or when you're doing
lifting movements sometimes it'll scrape
your shins sometimes it just looks cool
robin crossfit question my hamstrings
are super
tight have been for a few days now
what's the best stretch to help with
this
thanks some of the best stretches for
your hamstring are going to be
you can put your foot up on a raised box
or plates whatever we have so you get
that stretch in your hamstring there
this can also be performed
in a doorway or on a pull-up rig where
you're going to raise your foot up on
that
leave your other leg straight on the
ground and you'll feel a stretch that
way
one other one that i like to do as well
is when you put a band around your leg
you're going to lay back on the ground
and then
pull some tension on your hamstring to
where you feel comfortable
where you're not going to injure
yourself further sarah ray crossfit
question
tore my hand open doing pull-ups trim
off skin flap or leave it
ick ick is right when you do high volume
gymnastics sometimes
a whole flap of your skin comes off i
personally like to cut that off
it's gonna hurt like heck when you wash
your hands with soap and water and once
you do that make sure you're taking care
of a
second skin or things like that with
tape that you can put over it to kind of
keep you
from tearing even further but it will
hurt
and that is what they call kind of like
welcome to crossfit
sensai of death anybody with tire
flipping experience
what is the recommended start weight of
a tire to flip tire flips are going to
be full body
and they're very difficult and nasty if
the tires are dirty
when you actually heave that up it's
going to be a lot of your leg drive your
core and trunk stability your glutes so
definitely in a tire flip you want to
have the right technique of getting
underneath it
make sure you set your core and your
breath so you're nice and tight
and then you're going to drive that up
with our legs big chest up instead of a
rounded back
once you get it here you're going to
flip it over here and push it over
so recommended weight would be something
light where your technique is on point
and then you can start building to the
heavy kaza
crossfit in an hour should i eat before
or wait till after
i'm hungry i'm always hungry as well i
usually start out my sessions with the
strength portion in the beginning
and then get into the conditioning
pieces some people can eat 30 minutes
before some people need to eat three
hours before so it doesn't come back
up charisse b why are overhead squats
hurting my knees
crossfit question overhead squats are
going to be one of the most
difficult movements that we do because
it requires a lot
of mobility so an overhead squat is
taking
a barbell or any piece of equipment a
dumbbell a kettlebell
holding it above our head in a position
that allows us to squat
everyone is going to have a different
range of motion some people are hyper
flexible where they can go all the way
back
some people get stuck here a drill is
coming down onto a box and putting your
arms above it
pushing your head down so you'll feel a
stretch that way or a child's pose
that'll kind of open up
everything starting out super light you
can start out with a pvc pipe
just to kind of drill the positions make
sure you go
down to only where it's comfortable
until you're not feeling any pain
will h how do crossfit people create the
workouts
crossfit does have their staple workouts
so
fran everyone this is the dreaded fran
it's
21 thrusters with a barbell
it's a squat into an overhead press 21
of those
21 pull-ups 15 thrusters 15 pull-ups
9 thrusters 9 pull-ups leaves people on
the floor
breathing seeing stars there's annie
there's
kelly there's helen so there's all
different types of girl workouts
and then we also have hero workouts for
those are for the fallen soldiers those
are going to be
long very hard they are dedicated to
someone who gave their life for our
country
the biggest one is called murph we
usually do it on memorial day
and so that is going to be a one mile
run
100 pull-ups 200 push-ups 300 air squats
and a mile run in a weighted vest so
that's one of our staple hero workouts
melanin monroe is crossroad better than
traditional lifting does it bring
faster results i wouldn't say one is
technically better than the other it all
depends on what you're looking for
it will get you great results because
mixing up your cardio with your
weightlifting
is going to be very difficult and
intense i
love the competition setting and the fun
part of being here is that it's for
anyone of any fitness level
to come in and get in shape sandra
gutiers
says why is crossfit so expensive with
the crying emoji
it is a little more pricey than some of
the other gyms you'll come across
i think a big component of that is we do
spend time working
on so many different movements and
making sure that each person
is prepared knows technique and is
moving correctly
and so that's why maybe you're paying a
little bit
more than you would get at a gym where
you have to go in and think of the
workout yourself
joseph cohen question for crossfitters
and owners of crossfit boxes
how much do you work on your wrist
strength it's a missing link for many
in the very beginning it is
uncomfortable you might be doing
movements that you're not really used to
in your wrist
and you can have a lot of pain or little
things that bother you
so wrist wraps are going to be there's
all different kinds there's some are
velcro some are like a tie but they are
going to help you out because we do
do a lot of wrist intensive movements so
it'll just give you a little bit more
support
kind of like a lifting belt gives you
support when you're squatting
so that's kind of the same thing but
just for everest jenny has a question
for crossfit enthusiasts
do i need to be in shape already for my
first visit in the box
that is what you call it right you do
not need to be in shape when you come to
your very first visit that is
our job we work with people of all
different levels so from beginners
intermediate and advanced you all will
be in the same setting but we have
scales and modifications for
everyone so come as you are all right
ghostly father smith question to what
extent
should one squat bend at the knee for a
kettlebell swing
i was taught more hip bend than squat
but her movement is more half and half
any rule of thumb
in a kettlebell swing it is more of a
hinge than a squat
so our kettlebell swings are going to be
explosive coming from your hips
they are going to train full body so
unlock your knees
hand your hips back there is no rule of
thumb for
specific angles or how much of a knee
bend you should have you will have a
slight flexion
but you're focusing more on that hip
bend than
a knee squat michelle crossfit games
what is the ultimate goal of someone who
is competing in the crossfit games
people's answers will vary there is a
cash prize you are the fittest
man or woman on earth for people like me
my goal was to make it it was a
huge achievement just to get into the
top 40 women in the entire world
of course while i gave it my best effort
while i was there
was i trying to win first place
yeah but i was happy just to be there
and be competing amongst
all these amazing men and women and
that's it
these were some great questions hope to
see you guys in the box
until next time